welcome back now new figures out this
morning from the offers for National
statistics show that although the
unemployment rate remains pretty much
the same slightly more people are now in
work with part-time staff driving up the
numbers let's get more on this with the
director general of the British Chambers
of Commerce Siobhan Haviland good to see
you should that have said slightly more
people are out of work than than
previous uh unemployment figures and and
indeed what do these figures tell you
about the health of the UK economy
generally this morning yeah so so the
numbers have improved slightly but we
still have 1.1 million open roles in
this country which means that businesses
are still really struggling to find
people and that is impacting the growth
of their businesses so our businesses
are telling us they still can't find
enough people they can't fulfill their
order books they can't keep their hotel
running at capacity and it's a real
Challenge and would you say that is that
is the major issue that the UK economy
is facing right now is this shortfall in
in the Workforce that people just
haven't returned to work after the
pandemic it's absolutely the number one
thing that our businesses are telling us
they're struggling with their energy
bills too but finding people is is the
number one thing and that is not just
people not returning after the pandemic
uh it is parents struggling with child
care we want to see simpler more
affordable child care it is getting
older people back into work but it's
also all around just shortages of people
so we are saying to the government we'd
like them to review their shortage
occupation list so we can bring people
into the economy in certain sectors at
the right time and what would make a
difference what would what would help
with this Workforce shortfall that we're
seeing in the country so I would say a
couple of things uh spring budget is
coming up so we'd like to see the chance
to do something on child care and that
might be affordability of child care but
also Supply it's important to retrain
older people to get them back into work
and businesses need to have flexible
shifts for that but it's also a question
of looking at how we can bring more
labor into the market and just very
briefly how much have strikes impacted
and exacerbated our economic pain
it's another challenge for business
business like Clarity and certainty so
they can invest this just adds more
stress into the system so it's really
important for everyone to get around the
table and fix the problems now the IMF
recently forecast that we would be the
only leading economy to slide into
recession this year do you agree with
that do you see do you see that
happening it's going to be a challenging
year it is and we're still going to see
labor shortages and challenges around
energy bills but I have the pleasure of
traveling the country and meeting
businesses all over our regions and
Nations and they are resilient and they
are can do and they will find Solutions
but it is going to be a tough year
tougher here than elsewhere
it's going to be tougher yes but it's
tough for everyone okay she won't have a
land it's been really good to see you
and talk to you about this thanks so
much for joining us